hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel in today's video
we'll be discussing something that's
often overlooked by a lot of individuals
wanting to venture into the field of
machine learning data science and even
artificial intelligence chat Deputy the
buzzword today it relies heavily on gpus
for its AI training as they can handle
massive amounts of data and computations
faster than CP according to a report on
LinkedIn industry sources quoted that
chair GPT has imported at least 10 000
high-end Nvidia gpus and drive sales of
Nvidia related products from 3 billion
to 11 billion dollars within 12 months
sounds like a lot of gpus and investment
right it actually is for large models
intensive and advanced gpus are required
to train and test your data this is
where cloud computing comes in but the
question is which tools to use for
creating and deploying your amazing
projects on the cloud well worry not
because we are going to discuss the same
in this video we'll be discussing the
top five most unique time saving and
money saving tools that AWS the world's
largest cloud service provider has for
AIML related tasks so without any
further Ado let's jump on to our topic
whether you're a fresher or an IT expert
with some experience you can improve
your skills in cloud computing by
getting the proper training and
certifications on that note we present
to you the postgraduate program in cloud
computing by simplylearn this
postgraduate program in cloud computing
designed in collaboration with Caltech
ctme helps you become an Azure AWS and
gcp expert this in-depth cloud computing
certification course lets you master key
architectural principles and develop the
skills needed to become a cloud expert
benefits of this postgraduate program
includes Caltech ctme postgraduate
certificate enrollment in simply learns
job assist you will receive up to 30
CEUs from Caltech ctme similan's job
assist helps you get noticed by the top
hiring companies live virtual classes
led by industry experts Hands-On
projects and integrated Labs 40 plus
Hands-On projects and integrated Labs
along with Capstone project in four
different domains you will also get a
caltex etme circle membership you can
also fast track your career with this
cloud computing certification and its
in-depth course curriculum which covers
the key concept of azure AWS and gcp
platforms and services such as AWS
Lambda Amazon S3 and Azure app services
and many more other things this program
also covers the essential skills to
become an expert in cloud computing and
you can consider this program because it
provides you with a certification from
Caltech ctme a well-reputed university
in the United States so what are you
waiting for check out the link mentioned
in the description box below so without
any further delay let's start with what
is AWS Amazon web service or AWS is a
comprehensive cloud computing platform
offered by amazon.com
it provides a wide range of services
tools and infrastructure for building
and deploying applications and services
in the cloud
so let's discuss the top five tools
provided by this Cloud giant for AI and
machine learning first on our list is
the Amazon Siege maker this tool is a
game changer when it comes to building
training and deploying machine learning
models at scale with sagemaker you can
access a fully managed environment
eliminating the need to worry about
infrastructure management
you can choose from a wide range of
built-in algorithms and Frameworks or
bring your own to build powerful models
it takes care of automatic model tuning
optimizing your models for better
performance
the benefits of Amazon sagemaker are
plenty it provides scalability allowing
you to handle large data sets and
complex models effortlessly
you can also deploy your models with a
single click making them available for
real-time predictions plus with
automatic model tuning you save time and
Achieve higher accuracy it's a complete
end-to-end solution for all your machine
learning needs next up we have Amazon
recognition this tool leverages the
power of deep learning to analyze images
and videos enabling you to extract
valuable insights and automate various
tasks imagine being able to
automatically detect objects scenes and
faces in your visual data Amazon
recognition can do that and much more it
can recognize celebrities analyze text
within images and even assess emotions
the possibilities are endless
the benefits of Amazon recognition are
remarkable it offers powerful image and
video analysis capabilities allowing you
to gain valuable insights from visual
data it is highly scalable so you can
process millions of images and videos
without a hitch with its simple API you
can seamlessly integrate recognition
into your applications and workflows
making it accessible for all have you
ever wondered what it feels to have a
successful career in the field of cloud
computing so let's take a minute to hear
it from a learner who have experienced
massive success in their career
and I am currently living I wanted to
experience what is like to me I also
realized that to get a new job I needed
to have a professional certification in
cloud computing so last year I started
the postgraduate program in cloud
computing in association with culture
with this course I had the choice to
study while I can turn it and that is
how I got this new job offer with 60
percent salary high in Finland I will be
leading the cloud computing unit we
cannot wait to start our new life in
Finland we are also excited now let's
talk about Amazon comprehend this tool
is all about understanding and
extracting meaning from text Data making
it a must-have for any business dealing
with unstructured text with Amazon
comprehend you can perform tasks like
sentiment analysis entity recognition
and language detection it allows you to
gain insights from customer feedback
identify important entities in documents
and categorize text into relevant topics
the benefits of Amazon comprehend are
remarkable it offers accurate natural
language processing capabilities
supporting multiple languages and
providing powerful insights it is easy
to use and you can even train it with
your own data to create custom models
with comprehend you can unlock the value
hidden in your unstructured text
effortlessly or fourth tool on the list
is Amazon forecast
this tool is a game changer when it
comes to Accurate demand forecasting and
predictions
it uses machine learning to help
businesses optimize their operations and
make data-driven decisions Amazon
forecast can be used to predict product
demand resource requirement and
financial metrics it automatically
handles data cleaning and pre-processing
saving you time and effort with scalable
forecasting capabilities you can handle
large-scale data sets and obtain
accurate predictions the benefits of
Amazon forecast are remarkable it
provides accurate predictions helping
you optimize Inventory management
resource planning and financial
forecasting it automatically cleans your
data making forecasting a breeze plus it
seamlessly integrates with other AWS
Services making it a powerful tool for
any business last but not least we have
Amazon personalized this tool enables
you to deliver personalized customer
experiences improving engagement and
satisfaction with Amazon personalized
you can create real-time recommendations
tailored to each individual user whether
it's personalized product
recommendations content suggestions or
targeted marketing campaigns whether
it's personalized product
recommendations contain suggestions or
targeted marketing campaigns
personalized can help you increase user
engagement and drive conversions
the benefits of Amazon personalize are
exceptional it enables you to deliver
personalized recommendations enhancing
the user experience it offers easy
integration with your applications and
websites making implementation seamless
and with continuous learning
capabilities it keeps improving
recommendations based on user feedback
and there you have it the top 5 AWS
machine learning tools that can
transform your business and help you
Leverage The Power of AI whether you are
building models analyzing images and
text making accurate forecasts or
delivering personalized experiences AWS
has got you covered these tools offer a
wide range of features and benefits that
can revolutionize the way you work with
data and unleash its full potential
thank you for joining us today I hope
you found this overview of top 5 AWS
machine learning tools informative and
helpful if you have any questions then
please feel free to reach out stay tuned
for more exciting Tech content in the
future until then stay safe and keep
learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
thank you